hello and welcome to this webinar by a
surgeon in conjunction with lab roots on
next-generation sequencing lessons and
translational diagnostics mining and
migrating robust cancer biomarkers to
unified DNA and RNA NGS panels my name
is scary Latham I'm the vice president
for research and technology development
that is sure Jen and I'll be one of your
speakers today I'll be joined by my
colleague dr. Brian Haines senior
scientist and computational biology with
Ana surgeons Wow informatics department
so what we'd like to cover in this
webinar today is to share some of the
lessons that we've learned over several
years of developing validating and
implementing NGS based tests for
clinical use we'd like to do this in
four parts part one laying the
foundation how do you wire together a
comprehensive and integrated targeted
NGS system for clinical applications for
a routine patient testing and also to
advance drug development and support
clinical trials part two turning on the
light biomarker discovery is an
intrinsically complex endeavor made more
difficult and challenging clinical
specimens such as ffpe tumor biopsies
and this part Brian will describe how
we've used whole transcriptome RNA seek
lessons that identifying RNA biomarkers
in FP part three connecting the dots
identifying a biomarker is really just
the first step and a key subsequent
activity is how to take genome-scale
methodologies and those markers and
migrate them as a small footprint assays
that can be run routinely in the
clinical laboratory in this segment
Brian will describe how we've been able
to develop targeted RNA seek assays that
incorporate these novel biomarkers and
how we've been able to migrate them from
n to P even to a novel sample type in
this case fine needle aspiration
biopsies and finally part for putting it
all together I'll wrap up by describing
how we've taken DNA biomarkers and RNA
biomarkers including novel
cheers and incorporated them into a
unified total nucleic acid base clinical
NGS workflow where we can move beyond
the value of any single marker and
instead query pathway dysfunctions that
are relevant for a range of different
clinical questions well then have time
for conclusions and each of these
segments and then open the floor for
questions
if you do have a question there's a Q&A
box the lower left of your screen you're
welcome to inner questions in at any
point during the webinar will certainly
try to address as many as we can at the
end and for those that we can address
will certainly follow up and necessary
part one laying the foundation this
segment we'd like to describe how to
build and implement comprehensive and
targeted NGS system from translational
Diagnostics what some of the key
considerations are in this process
clinical testing requires tight
integration across all facets of the
workflow yet commercial NGS reagents are
often provided for research use as such
as put the burden on clinical
laboratories to patch together different
components into a workflow that can
yield less than desirable results so our
mission and surgeon has been to optimize
each and every component of the workflow
and then link them together in a way
that can meet the clinical requirements
for the ingest based testing for example
for sample stabilization surgeon as an
fda-cleared RNA retain region stabilizes
RNA in clinical specimens and can help
protect that RNA for downstream assays
like targeted RNA seek for DNA RNA or
even told them to quake isolation
surgeon scientists have expertise it
dates back to the am beyond heritage and
developing technologies for mouth fluids
for FSP for finding laceration samples
and those technologies have been
significantly advanced over the past few
years in areas where there have been
lapses in these workflows like in
process QC metrics and assays we've
developed those assays where necessary
and one of the ones that like to talk
about today is to fi DNA assay as well
as if you apply RNA assay
then target enrichment our focus has
been on pcr to enrich for targets of
interest because it's so well vetted for
diagnostic purposes we've built
large-scale multiplexers using this
methodology can ensure even coverage and
then ultimately channeling this
information into the analysis pipeline
be able to make confident calls that are
relevant for clinical applications but
in addition to linking all these pieces
together it's also important to
integrate across different segments of
the asset and one of the points that
really like to highlight today is how
our ability to interrogate the
quantitative characteristics of the
sample itself that information can be
used in form the analysis pipeline this
can get much more reliable data this
slide provides a workflow of this
process from pre-analytical the
analytical to the post analytical phases
and add specifications on top of what I
mentioned previously for example in the
pre analytical phase the Q ified DNA
assay allows us to really understand how
much of a sample we have the actionable
at the DNA or even the RNA level and how
they can be input into the analytical
phase in reaction to generate reliable
results the analytical phase we
typically use a range of different
enrichment technologies based on pcr
backing the key point is that we've
developed these technologies to
accommodate the worst possible scenario
of sample so that once we built these
assays they can be applied to SSP or
even by fordham specimens and then
ultimately the bioinformatics did you
consider all this information including
the noise that is intrinsic within a
given clinical sample to be able to make
the right interpretation another key
feature is in controls so although we
and many in the community find example
purified DNA from cancer so ons to be
very helpful and they certainly are we
do favor using residual clinical
materials whenever possible and for this
reason the surgeon has access to 100,000
member FFP tumor bank for assay
development and for validation
so let's put a spotlight on the
pre-analytical phrase for some of the
technical challenges of state
development of ngf assays certainly one
of those challenges is with the sample
itself and particularly ffpe specimens
so these samples are known to have
relatively load DNA and RNA quality of
course you look at these different
blocks you can't possibly tell which one
has lower versus slightly higher quality
methods like spectrophotometry or a
nanodrop or equally blind they report to
some bulk nucleic acid until you nothing
about functionality in downstream assays
for instance page essay is like cubic
are more informative but actually
they're just as one for the lowest
quality sample because the greatest risk
to misinterpretation NGS essays but
there is a method that works it works
well it's called the qfi a saint when
that we've developed specifically to
address this gap in sample
characterization going into in gsm phase
secure fine stands for the quantity of
functional index and what sagesse to
finance it does is it measures a
fraction of amplified will DNA in a
sample so to finance a score three
percent we're correspond to three
amplifier will template to the
background of 100 DNA template when we
compare the qf is a score to a relative
DNA concentration measured using like a
cubed assay you can see there's a
general relationship between these two
assays for the higher quality DNA
samples but this race relationship falls
apart for the role of quality samples
but once you drop below about three
percent in the qf is a score cupid is no
longer informative ignore the qf i assay
itself has a very broad dynamic range
you can quantify well below this point
the challenge here is that it's these
low quality samples that typically a
most at risk to generate false negatives
and soft positives I think a clear
demonstration of the fact is shown in
this slide which summarizes data that we
generated across 44 ffp tumor specimens
that are profiled using the ampliphi
cancer panel
these apples represented a range of
different DNA quality each point in this
plot represents a distinct sample if the
samples that have relatively high
quality hi to apply a search for the
number of variants generally between 10
and 15 is consistent with expectation
however once you drop below about 6% qfi
at that point with a sharp rise in the
total number of variants that are
detected in this case using the Ion
Torrent column the reason for this is
that you're moving into a range or the
app takes less robust and it can be
stochastic cause particularly limited
protection that's flare-up so it's
critical to understand the nature of the
sample because bioinformatics you can
treat this this is not an eyesore or
problem an interpretation that can't be
remedied it can but it can't be remedied
with a flat threshold it takes a
different approach so we've applied the
qf is a to a broad expanse of specimens
and this slide summarizes assay results
from nearly 2,000 residual clinical FFPE
samples 13 distinct cohorts and the
majority of these are drawn from working
with pharmaceutical customers so as a
result there to conclusions that can be
taken from this slide the first
conclusion is that SSP DNA is generally
of low quality so the median purify
asus4 here is less than ten percent the
second conclusion is that there's a
broad range of quality and it can vary
by as much as 25 fold from cohort to
cohort for example this cohort
represents relatively high quality for a
few samples with a purifying and I
scored twenty-six percent or is this
cohort represents a much lower score of
less than one percent challenges for DNA
in terms of quality also pertain to RNA
and the summary here shows with FB RNA
that across four different measures of
quality or qualification that greater
than 200 nucleotide fraction on the
bioanalyzer compared to nanodrop cubed
and because I asked if I athlete by far
is the best score
relation with a unique economic content
than that in fact there's a relationship
between not only Keo find the quality
but also the value of increasing the
input is a way to recover and rescue
samples and generate more useful
information is shown the plot here at
the lower right this also pertains to
the DNA so we know that if we increase
the input from DNA for low quality
samples that we can rescue false
negatives and also help cure false
positives they can occur so moving on to
the analytical phase there are number
different questions that are important
in the uncle realm in this particular
area what's the workflow you're going to
use what's for content appropriate for
either routine clinical testing or for
clinical trial work what is the best
platform or can you use multiple
platforms together in a way that can be
more valuable than anyone on its own
what are the right controls to use and
ultimately how can you build a work for
with the right content on the right
platform with the right controls to have
a turnaround time that's responsive for
both patient testing and for drug
development in clinical trials the one
of the panels like the highlight here is
our sure c500 panel or we've developed
specifically for clinical purposes this
is one of more than a dozen of such
panels that we've developed it's the
most mature it targets 17 oncogenes and
represents more than 500 mutations index
and cosmic which is why it's called Chi
rasika 500 this is a panel that we've
implemented into our clinical laboratory
in accordance with the camp check was
for a next-generation sequencing and
it's been optimized to achieve high
analytical sensitivity and high ppv
after about five percent arian detection
and FFP samples across a range of
different quality including some of the
more problematic very low quality
samples in terms of input what can be as
well as an anagram but again we don't
really think about both input because
the relevant factor to consider is copy
number and template complexity what is a
repertory of actionable templates that
will go into the work for
I'd like to show how we can put the
pieces together is it pertains to our
CLIA validation of this particular panel
and rather than using mixtures of cancer
cell line DNA our approach was to use
residual clinical FFP DNA but you can't
just mix any two samples it's critical
that these are matched by the two fi
asus4 otherwise you'll have a
disproportionate of template quantities
in the tube when you mix them in a
certain ratio you won't get the expected
results in this case we compared two
different samples that actually had a
match to purify assage for nine percent
so that they can be mixed in an exact
mathematical proportion to give a
variant abundance and one of these
samples had three CA and a que
recitation the other sample has a BF
v600e mutation we mix them at different
levels we're able to show is that going
down your limit of analytical
sensitivity a theoretical 4.4% variant
was detected at six percent four and a
half percent krad variant is detected at
four percent and in the converse
titration a Bureau at four percent was
detected at four point eight percent so
this is the relevant experiment
petitioners exact clinical specimens
being evaluated in the context of how
this NGS essay is implemented by
clinical app so moving on to the post
analytical phase we understand that
obviously there's a lot of complexity
here but within complexity lies a lot of
opportunity for innovation so going
through the various steps of this
workflow to demultiplex to align to the
reference genome assess the coverage and
then define variants that can be
detected with confidence and they're
ultimately out put it in a patient
report requires that you consider each
of these steps with their own
incremental qcs and with an
understanding of the sample itself so to
give you an example of how we've used
different components of this work for an
information output to help inform the
informatics consider two samples sample
has shown at the top here as a key FA a
fish for a forty three percent this is a
high quality
p DNA across the six possible to base
hypotheses you can see that there's an
elevation in the variant background its
associated with TGT a transitions if we
compare that with a sample that has
tenfold lower quality in this case a
cure finance a score of four percent you
can see a general trend that's similar
among these experience hypotheses in
terms of their variant background but
now there's an exaggeration extreme
inflammation in the variant background
for sociated with the cgt a transition
much much higher I think in the
personalized medicine age will retreat
each patient is an individual based on
their individual tumor profile it's
important to remember that behind each
patient is a sample and in the same
spirit it's critical that we treat
samples individually clearly there to
make sense reply out I have threshold
across variants for each one of these
hypotheses they have to be adapted to
the specific characteristic the
quantitative characteristics of the
sample and that's the value of using
information like that you apply asus4 to
build that information into the
bioinformatics pipeline so we've rolled
all this information together in a very
user-friendly html5 interface called
sure aside this allows the users to
browse through all different domains of
the data from the coverage to Kesey's to
the variant calls etc and we find this
to be a very helpful resource for how
complex data can be distilled and
interpreted importantly this taps into
the fact that we've have just used a
hodgepodge of publicly available tools
that these are innovative bioinformatics
algorithms been built based on profiles
of the clinical samples they're intended
to test like FFP and is a true measure
of that integration this is showing you
just one of the outputs from sure site
it's not just the conventional coverage
information so get but also the
pre-analytical sample QC to a finance a
score is hardwired into this report this
is a sample it's demonstrated with a
very low GFI has three percent GFI so
this is exactly the type of sample that
would be likely to generate large number
of
Arians and downstream in gs however if
you look at the final output from this
particular sample rather than dozen
during the hundreds of variants we've
been able to do this still down to a
single variant single cosmic in Rask's
mutation together pile up here at
fourteen percent so this is the level of
clarity that can be observed when one
uses pre-analytical information to power
the bioinformatics so i'd like to wrap
up at this point with what we've learned
well first and foremost it's garbage in
garbage out you have to understand the
sample nana draft is essentially random
number generator cubic is better but not
nearly good enough and this is like
you'll find DNA assay and this is jeff
IRNA assay for RNA can be the most
useful metric that we found today tins
the extensively tested with up to 2,000
samples and with a great deal of india's
outputs de validated it's also important
to use controls that are truly
representative the specimens you're
going to test and we've really focused
on FSP for that purpose and finally you
should never do bioinformatics in a
vacuum it's really critical to leverage
a pre-analytical sample data and other
inputs across the workflow and QC
metrics to make sure that you can draw
the right conclusions so i'll wrap up at
this point and turn it over to Brian for
the next segment
thank you Gary this is part two turning
on the light in this segment Elvis got
to help to shed light on the dark matter
of cancer through the application of RNA
seek to ffpe tumor biopsies is well
appreciated in cancer that the
distribution of mutation frequencies
follows a power law distribution
sometimes referred to as the long tail
of cancer TCGA and other consortia are
powering their way toward the end of
this tale using pan-cancer approaches to
identify ultra rare driver mutations
driver mutations in cancer both common
and rare impinge on a core set of
pathways by coupling RNA expression
profiling with DNA mutation sequencing
we can begin to interpret the
implications of these driver mutations
as a pathway level this is extremely
important in the context of a clinical
setting where you may have a particular
specimen that does not have a known
driver mutation using the RNA expression
read out to determine the state
dysregulated pathways can allow a
clinician to make a determination as to
the diagnostic state of the sample or
which therapy a subject may respond to
one important class of specimens that
can help to enable the discovery but
pathway level signatures are ffpe tumor
biopsies over 20 million ffpe tissue
biopsies are archived each year in the
US alone and this class of samples is
richly annotated with histopathology and
response to therapeutics data the RNA
obtained from FFPE samples is
heterogeneous in quality and it is
compromised along two principal axes
first there are reversible chemical
modifications in the RNA
such as deamination and a deck formation
these modifications introduce sequencing
errors and they also reduce the
efficiency of certain stages of RNA seek
library prep RNA from ffpe is also
degraded and therefore cannot be used
poly eight enriched for our native
library clips alternative approaches
must be used the degradation is
heterogeneous as you can see in this
plot on the right I'm showing
bioanalyzer traces for three different
samples you can see the extent of
degradation Gary's across the examples
both the compromise nature of f of Te
RNA and the heterogeneity that we see in
these cohorts introduces several
challenges for RNA steep QC library prep
and downstream informatics a surgeon had
developed an integrated whole
transcriptome RNA seek workflow that is
compatible with ffpe RNA starting from
degraded RNA we apply a qfi qpcr assay
to determine the functionality of the
material after applying this assay we
subject the RNA to a ribosomal RNA
depletion step followed by RT and
tagging strand-specific libraries are
then amplified and then sequenced on an
aluminum flow cell with a 2 by 50
paired-end reaction target read depth of
15 million reads per library the
resulting phasic use are assessed by a
bioinformatic QC process and then a
whole genome splice the line that is
performed after performing this
alignment we break out into different
types of analyses two of which I'll
discuss today in detail first we look at
isoform and transcript quantitation from
these alignments we also perform
mutation and in Dell calling as well as
fusion detection each of these analyses
can be integrated and summarized under a
compact reporting system that we have
developed at a surgeon
called sure sight the informatics
challenges with ffpe RNA seek start with
expression quantitation unlike intact
RNA and fresh frozen in which we can
apply a poly a prep the RNA that we see
in SF PG samples we see an increase the
level of intronic sequences and this is
illustrated by this igd plot at the top
right of this slide jerem showing for a
particular gene the FFPE reads
alignments compared to an in text sample
that was poly-a enriched and you can see
noticeably across the intronic reasons
of this gene there's a pile up the SPE
sample that's absent in the int example
and you can notice that this coverage is
restricted to the gene body suggestive
of nascent or pre-mrna and not Genoa
contamination most expression
quantitation algorithms that have given
that have been developed a date do not
take into account this high level of
pre-mrna a surgeon has overcome this
challenge by developing a robust
expression clot a shin and biomarker
selection pipeline that identifies and
markers from this compromise material
that generalized to other cohorts and
migrate to other assays a second
challenge with ffpe RNA seek is the
identification of driver fusions even
outside of ffpe the discovery of driver
fusion events in cancer is a challenging
problem due to the high disease
irrelevant background this background is
caused by several issues first we can
have alignment error between two
homologues that may look like a fusion
but is actually a false positive and we
can also have background driven by real
biology such as transit icing events
that occur in wild-type cells as well as
parents into your fusions there are not
actually causal agents of the disease
these challenges are further compounded
with the shorter fragment sizes that we
see typically and FM PE RNA seek
to overcome these challenges assure jen
has developed a very sensitive up front
fusion collar coupled with a cohort
adaptive filter that eliminates most
false positives are teeny high
sensitivity to date we have applied our
workflow over a wide range of ffpe
qualities and mass inputs into the
library prep this is illustrated by for
this figure on the right which we
performed a titration study using three
different FFPE samples all these samples
were graded by a qf is a and on the top
row we have a high-quality sample in the
middle row we have a medium quality
sample into the bottom row we have a low
quality sample what is what the spot is
showing is the technical concordance in
the first column between two 600
nanogram duplicates and then the
subsequent columns to the right we're
comparing one of those to 600 and Graham
duplicates to a lower mass input we can
see that across this plot the coverage
normalized coverage between these two
duplicates is maintained with a higher r
squared across this range of quality and
mass inputs you can see there is a
tailing off of those are squares but
they all maintain a level of point 98 or
greater as a more general statement
we've applied now RF fter NAC workflow
to over 500 clinical FFP es with a
success rate of approximately ninety
percent next I will discuss a case study
that we applied this whole transcriptome
rnase deep workflow to for the purposes
of discovering novel diagnostic
biomarkers in oncology this case study
focuses on improving molecular
diagnostics for thyroid cancer this is
motivated by the fact that the instance
rate of thyroid cancer is growing faster
than any other cancer an early
indication of thyroid cancer is a
thyroid nodule and these modules are
common in the US population but most are
but not
the diagnosis of a nodule consists of an
ultrasound-guided fine needle aspirate
that is followed by psychology and a
psychology of indeterminate molecular
typing is performed interrogating the
presence of common driver mutations in
thyroid cancers such as de RAF raft
packs appr gamma and red PT see many
nodules are indeterminate by psychology
and negative for these are common driver
mutations which motivates the need for
improved molecular diagnostics testing
in this case study we applied whole
transcriptome RNA seeds to a cohort of
68 SPE thyroid biopsies from surgical
resection those biopsies were sectioned
and assessed by a pathologist to
determine the status of the nine versus
malignant and further sub typed into
different categories of follicular and
papillary thyroid carcinomas and for the
benign samples sub typed into follicular
add nomas Reuters and nodular
hyperplasia all these samples we also
performed at luminex assay to test for
the presence of common driver mutations
including rafts be rafts xat bear gamma
and Brent PTC the pie chart on the right
is showing the fraction of the malignant
samples that were tested positive for
one of these common driver mutations
next we isolated RNA from these ffpe
blocks and performed whole transcriptome
RNA seek this is an assessment of the
overall QC that we see for this cohort
the highest Ren that we obtained for all
these examples was 2.6 and this is
typical of FFP we Generalissimo samples
as being fairly degraded another QC
metric that is being used more recently
is the DB 200 metrics and for this
covert we have fourteen percent of the
samples that show less than thirty
percent DD 200 metrics and for those of
you who don't know the DD two hundred
metric is for a particular sample and
this is
formed by it bioanalyzer trace the
diffraction of RNA fragments in that
sample that exceed 200 nucleotides in
size one of these samples failed the
library prep outright but all the other
samples are shown below the one sample
that had a DB two hundred metric right
at thirty percent is highlighted with
the bull bar at the bottom and what
we're looking at in this plot the bottom
is where the reads are mapping to the
genome post sequencing you can see the
sample with the DB 200 right at thirty
percent is mapping was about thirty
percent exonic content and it's sitting
right in the middle of our cohort all
these samples that passed that succeeded
library prep so excluding one sample
were moved on into the biomarker
discovery phase of this project we
applied a variance culture to eliminate
low variance potential biomarkers and
arrived at a set of 20 just over 21,000
candidate biomarkers to distinguish
benign from malignant lesions this is
looking at now with a different view of
that same PCA plot the two principal
sources of variation in the data that
those candidate biomarkers are driving
and we see a separation here when over
plotting the samples belongs to those
two principal sources of variation of
the papillary thyroid carcinomas which
are circled in red in this plot those
are papillary thyroid carcinomas are
separating from the benign lesions as
well as the follicular carcinomas and
this is a very promising indication
leading in to supervise biomarker
discovery feature selection and this
type of unsupervised analysis is
something we typically apply just to get
a sense of the data to see if the
principal sources of variation in a
candidate set of biomarkers is showing
some type of class separation next we
moved in to supervise biomarker
selection and selected the top 25
biomarkers from this cohort
that could distinguish benign from
malignant lesions and could form a
signature to classify benign from
malignant lesions I'm showing those 25
markers here in these two separate plots
plot on the left is showing the FFPE
cohort with each marker plotted in a
different panel the y-axis is the
expression level of the marker and the
samples are broken out based on their
respective subtypes the benign samples
are colored in blue and green and the
employment samples are colored in orange
yellow and red you can see that some of
these workers are showing up regulation
and malignant relatives to the nines
whereas others show down regulation the
plot on the right is showing the same
markers from the perspective of the TCGA
cohort which is fresh fresh frozen and
it lacks benign samples but it does
include for some for some tumors it
include them matched normal adjacent as
well as a matched met so what this plot
is showing as you can see when you look
at the same marker in both plots is that
markers that are down-regulated in
malignant samples are showing
downregulation down-regulation in the
primary and maps relative to the normal
adjacent in TCGA and just to zoom in on
one of those markers that show an
upregulation in a malignant and oblivion
to the samples in the SPE cohort here
we're seeing a concordant upregulation
in the primary and that relative to the
normal adjacent and the TCGA
fresh-frozen cohort this trend and sign
consistency of the effects was
consistent for nearly every marker that
we selected and this is a very promising
indication when leading into the next
phases that potentially migrating the
signature into a clinical apps a to
distinguish 49 from malignant lesions
and other cohorts now I want to take a
step back and look at a different type
of analysis that we apply to whole
transcriptome RNA seek these with the
intent of identifying novel driver
fusions
we applied our some confusion calling
pipeline to the whole transcriptome RNA
seek data in the 68 sample cohort and
identify the total of roughly 40,000
fusions the color that we use pretty
upfront fusion detection is highly
sensitive but it also includes many
false positives and it is highly
sensitive to deal with the nature of
ffpe a shorter fragment sizes now we
eliminate most of these false positives
through the application of a pervert
adaptive filter that we apply and this
reduces the set of approximately 40,000
fusions by three orders of magnitude to
give you a sense of what the cohort
adaptive filter is doing we consider
three different collapses or fusions
first we look at adjacent fusion so
fusions that are formed from two
adjacent genes these are often due to
read through events we also look at
enter a chromosomal and intrachromosomal
events the plot on the right is showing
the frequency at which different types
of samples benign or malignant are
covered by one or more of these classes
of events the fusions are ranked
according to a score that takes into
account the background frequency of the
three and five prime partners in each
fusion now we set a score cutoff for
each of these classes independently that
enrich is for the malignant presence of
fusions and malignant samples relative
to the nines using a Fisher's exact test
to set the cutoff this eliminates as i
said the set of kin diffusions down to
41 all 41 of these were tested by n
point TCR and 26 of them were confirmed
by Sanger sequencing we followed up this
confirmation by Sanger to test the
presence of these 26 events in both
benign and malignant samples using a
more sensitive assay and confirm that 15
of these 26 fusions are in fact specific
to malignancies the remaining events are
likely to be transient events that occur
in wild-type cells
looking at the fusions that we confirm
from the perspective of the malignant
samples that were previously negative
for the common driver mutations at forty
seven percent we can see now the two
thirds of those previously mutation
negative samples that are malignant
samples are now covered by one of these
fusion events that we detected of that
set seventeen percent of those fusions
have been published either in thyroid
cancer or another cancer type with fifty
percent of them were novel and those
novel fusions the three prime genes in
those fusions are dirty well known aqua
genes and known drive infusions the
driver commutation genes in both thyroid
cancer and other cancers suggested that
many of those novel fusions are back
driver fusions of the one sample type or
rather fusion type that we need to be
present in these samples which is taxi
PBR gamma this is present in three of
the 68 samples we were able to detect
this fusion with 100-percent sensitivity
and specificity using the pipeline that
we have applied which is the sensitives
fusion corridor followed by de the
cohort adaptive filter moving on to
recap what we have learned in the
section first of all given the right
combination of molecular and informatics
processes high-quality data can be
obtained from her sub te tumor biopsies
and we've demonstrated that through the
application of this case study in
thyroid cancer where we apply whole
transcriptome RNA seek coupled with a
surgeon's biomarker discovery pipeline
to identify expression biomarkers in FF
te specimens that generalize to other
cohorts including fresh frozen biopsies
finally we can apply a surgeon's fusion
pipeline discovery process to whole
transcriptome RNA seek to enable both
the reliable detection of known fusion
events as well as discover novel driver
fusions
now moving on to part three
this is part three connecting the dots
in this segment I'll discuss how to
navigate the transition from preclinical
exploratory discovery work to a clinical
assay using next-generation sequencing
the traditional past has been to perform
discovery on a high content platform
such as a microarray and then migrate a
set of biomarkers or signature on to a
smaller footprint assets such as a qpcr
the clinical assay often uses a
different isolation protocol sample
preps and quantitation chemistry's and
this results in platform specific
diocese and technical variances
differences in the dynamic range that
ultimately can lead to the laws of
markers and degraded signature
performance next-generation sequencing
offers the opportunity to de-risk this
process by unifying the discovery and
clinical assay development stages a
surgeon enables this unification through
sure seek targeted RNA seek which share
several common steps with whole
transcriptome RNA seek first it uses a
common isolation protocol to isolate
from either FFPE samples or a fine
needle aspirate it also uses a common RT
reaction to convert the RNA to cdna and
then it also shares the actual
measurement technology that these
libraries are destined for which is the
next-gen sequencing flow cell or PGM as
a case study to illustrate there's a
migration path from whole transcriptome
discovery and using RNA seek and fotd
samples and the migration of that
signature that was derived from that
study to sure she'd targeted RNA see
gasps a here we have a cohort where we
selected the 25 diagnostic biomarkers
just to distinguish 49 for malignant
lesions and thyroid cancer
those 25 markers along with 15
additional genes were migrated to a
targeted RNA see gasps a vision sure
seek the additional 15 genes included
doggedness controls and markers a stair
Gnostic value the sure Steve targeted
RNA seek workflow is as follows on the
right we start with isolated foreign aid
can perform qpcr based qf is a to assess
the functionality of the material this
assay is performed post RT that RT is
then fed into a targeted multiplex pcr
and tagging step those libraries are
then amplified and it's sequenced on a
next-gen sequencing instrument the 40
gene panel that we developed using the
sure c targeted RNA seek custom assay
design was applied to two different
cohorts first we applied it to a cohort
of 123 FFPE samples with known
pathologies this included the original
68 samples that we use to discover the
diagnostic signature and the prevalence
of this cohort was sixty-nine percent in
malignant the second cohort that we
applied this target RNA cpanel to with
this set of 65 fine needle aspirants for
which surgical outcome was known the
overall prevalence of this cohort was
fifty-six percent malignant we applied
after performing the targeted rnase you
can say to both of these cohorts two
different types of analyses first we
looked at the comparison of whole
transcriptome RNA sequence match samples
for targeted RNA seek to ensure that
there was good analytical concordance
between the discovery and the clinical
assay secondly we looked at the
diagnostic classifiers that we could
build from the targeted RNA sheath data
looking at classifiers built on FFPE
samples and then tested on mas
this plot is showing each of the 25
diagnostic markers that were selected
from the whole transcriptome ffpe covert
with comparison of all transcription RNA
seek along the y-axis compared to
targeted RNA seek along the x-axis each
of these is a different marker and some
of these markers actually are more
functioning as endogenous controls you
can see there's one marker that has
lower variance and the Senators plot by
both technologies but what we can see is
that nearly every single one of these
markers is showing very good concordance
between the two platforms the discovery
platform and the clinical platform next
we look at both cohorts by projecting
the markers that we measures onto a pc a
pipeline where we're separating both the
mockers by the principal sources of
variation and the data as well as the
samples and those are over plotted in
the colored squares one thing that
stands out in this plot first is that we
see a separation between the benign
samples and the malignant samples and
this separation is achieved for both the
essays as well as the FF pcs and the
point at which those samples separate
which is right at the dotted line is
roughly the same for both cohorts in
collection methods the second feature
that we see in this plot is the
separation of the FFPE samples shown on
top and the fna is shown in the bottom
and this separation upon closer
inspection of the markers that are
involved in pc 2 we found those markers
to be present at high levels in blood
and this is consistent with the fact
that FN a's are more prone to blood
contamination than ffpe s which is what
drives us effect finally moving into the
construction of several different
classifiers using this data the first
classifier that we developed
which is shown in blue was trained on
the SPE cohort the 123 ffpe and then
tested under leave-one-out
cross-validation on that same cohort the
accuracy that we're able to achieve with
this classifier is quite good the t you
see a point 94 and impressive
sensitivity and specificity numbers as
well the corresponding ROC curve is
shown highlighted in blue in the bottom
left and this finding is not actually
that surprising given the fact that
about half of this cohort was used to
perform the initial diagnostic
biomarkers selection so there is that a
bias baked in there the second
classifier that we built was trained on
the faa's and then tested on the engine
A's under leave-one-out cross-validation
and this result is actually telling us
something quite interesting first of all
it tells us that the given that the high
AUC sensitivity and specificity numbers
are retained in this code word tells us
that the discovery process of these
markers was successful we identified
markers that have diagnostic utility in
fnaf and those markers were discovered
and f of the Pease and then finally
looking at the last classifier that we
developed which is highlighted in green
this classifier was trained on the SMP e
cohort and then tested on the SMA and
this result I think is the most
compelling given that this classifier
both in terms of the content the markers
that are included as well as the
coefficients of the model have never
seen this small has never seen a fine
needle aspirate it's only been trained
on as a PDS and FFP either guided the
selection of those markers and in this
classifier we were able to retain very
high AC sensitivity and specificity in
the finding of aspirin / ward so moving
on to wrap up this section with what we
have learned first of all sure she
targeted RNA seek is those quantitative
and analytically concordance with our
discovery technology whole transcript
RNA seek secondly signatures that are
discovered develop and train on sfpd
biopsies using whole transcriptome RNA
seek and then migrated to target RNA
seek show clinical value in sna biopsies
finally suree seek is what enables the
unification of the discovery and
development phases of diagnostic
pipelines and with that I'll hand it
back to Gary for part four
work for putting it all together so in
this segment we're going to talk about
how we've been able to take DNA markers
and RNA markers including novel mrna
expression markers and translocation and
marry them within unified total nucleic
acid-based clinical workflow and I'd
like to focus today on the clinical case
study around thyroid cancer I think it's
important to note that our general
strategy and approach here is relevant
to many different cancers and
pathologies let me begin with an
overview of this particular unified and
gents workflow and I'd like to point out
a couple of key elements as we go along
since this is a thyroid clinical case
study it's important to provide context
on the acquisition of the sample type
which in this case is a biopsy it's
taken as an fna from the patient we're
able to utilize our RNA retain
technology to preserve the sample which
is critical because it includes RNA and
DNA markers and then we can use to fi an
assay to partition quantification of
votes that DNA and the RNA load within
total nucleic acids sample and that
really provides the first innovation
here we have the capability to take a
total nucleic acid which relieves us
from the requirement to independently
actual a DNA and RNA instead
individually query how much DNA and RNA
there is in a DNA sample and use it
accordingly we can then pass that
material into the enrichment portion of
the workflow and at that stage we're
looking at multiple different types of
markers and we're building a larger
panel that we have the opportunity that
has multiple clinical questions so
that's another innovative feature of
this particular case study that is that
it taps into multi-purpose clinical
content not just diagnosis of malignancy
but also markers they can have
informative insight into uptake of
radioactive iodine for patients with
thyroid cancer for potential prognostic
implications for these patients were
targeted therapy and Vera Gnostics etc
once that's been sequenced on the
appropriate in gs instrument it goes
into the integrated bioinformatics line
so going through our variant color
pipeline in the corresponding shura site
package for analysis then that's really
the third key innovation here because
we're looking across different pathways
we're integrating a constellation of
different types of markers from DNA
mutations and in belz to see and bees to
fusions and translocations and in mining
expression markers all of which can be
synthesized into an evidence-based
report we passed on to the actual at the
level of the patients so in terms of the
design of the panel's themselves since
we're interrogating both DNA and RNA we
have opportunities here to be able to
build the content in a way that provides
some additional benefits for example in
the DNA pools we're targeting a total of
twenty genes so those genes are
represented in low sigh spread across
two independent pools that are utilized
for enrichment however an interesting
feature of this that we've built into
the assay is the ability to have
overlapping content between the two DNA
pools so some of the most critically
important genes that are relevant in
clinical contexts of thyroid cancer like
the RAF and their ass jeans are so
important is vital to be able to make
very accurate calls on these particular
genes so we've designed the targets to
be completely independent in primer
designs across the two pools so that we
have built-in confirmations associated
with the outcome of the DNA variant
calling on the RNA side we have also two
pools one of these is dedicated to query
translocations or total of fifty-two
translocations and one of the RNA pools
and the other queries forty mrna markers
for expression and in a similar vein we
have controls at overlap between the two
pools to ensure integrity and the
results and interpretation so we're
covering a broad range of different
content for DNA and RNA and a workflow
that ultimately puts these two together
that create a very straightforward
approach for routine use
let me highlight then a few other novel
features the assay and how we can now
really put it all together with these
different innovations it spread across
the pre-analytical analytical and post
analytical components to the workflow so
let's consider something like till the
late answer they're pointing to and
analyze from the samples taken from the
patient in this case because thyroid
biopsy is often don't yield a great deal
of total nucleic acid it's important
that you don't overtly consume that
material that you see a thing and as a
result it led us to develop our qfi DNA
assay to be even more sensitive so
what's short in this plot is the advance
from our version one of the assay which
is shown in blue to version two of the
assay which is shown in red what we've
done is we've we've changed our approach
here that allows us to have much much
higher sensitivity and achieve accurate
quantification took less than point 05
genomic orleans so now we can use an
absolute positive material in the GC
portion and preserve as much material
necessary for the downstream analysis
another way we've used this assay is
that it allows us to do a very strict
molecular accounting of DNA and RNA in a
way that can inform the bioinformatics
and help us understand what our
confessionals can be take this example
this is a five percent beer at v600e FNA
that has been embedded in the background
of wild-type DNA and what's varying is
the total copy number of DNA across a
series the background of 5% variant is
held constant so what that means is that
a thousand total copies at pakistan
variant 50 mutant copies of erath and so
on down to 63 total copies and only
three copies of the raft mutant we know
this because we've been able to analyze
it quantitatively easy to fidm a essay
so now if we look at how this material
calls in the downstream in gssa you can
see that we're able to maintain a strict
quantification of the five percent level
at the higher inputs all the way down
until we get to about the
mutant point so you see these are done
in replicates and we waver with a drop
out at the lowest input which is only 63
total copies or three mutant copies d
rap so at that point we're really
getting to a stochastic range but we
have the ability now use this
information to help inform exactly what
our stability is for variant calling
even for low quantity samples what about
the RNA side we've used a number of
different statistical methods to be able
identify what's an appropriate RNA
normalizer for I read cancer we've
identified that marker and put it to
good work in a qf I RNAs a the plot
shown at the bottom here is a
representation of different inputs of
total mcquaig acid and the corresponding
copy number of that vetted RNA target
that's very stable expressed across a
range of different bowery subtypes of
cancer and benign conditions if we then
take that information and look
specifically at particular fusions that
may be detected that are clinically
relevant in this case our packs a QPR
gamma fusion in one clinical FNA and in
the other case erectus you fusion we're
able to show that down to about 125
nanograms total nucleic acid allows us
to achieve a ready detection of these
particular events with a corresponding
copy number our target which we can then
standardized as a consequence of input
into the acid an analytical performance
going through the enrichment process and
really vetting the answer on a larger
scale we can look at metrics associated
with sensitivity and btb that this plant
shows you the corresponding analytics
for DNA detection it's not just cancer
cell line controls in this case we're
looking 72 different specimens of which
69 or either put on or malignant
clinical FAS with known outcomes for
mutations and other variants and based
on the precision recall curve you can
see we generally have about
ninety percent sensitivity at ninety
percent PPG so it's a very high
performing as a down to about two
percent variant detection one of the
interesting features that this approach
as I alluded to is the fact that
confirmations are built into the asset
running to a season one for many of the
most clinically relevant targets and a
couple of examples of this on the DNA
side this data that shown in the print
slide is a care act's 261 our mutation
that was detected at a very low level
about three and a half percent within
one of the clinical FM age that we
tested and in the corresponding DNA pool
to this one with the orthogonal design
it was Detective two point nine nine
percent so high reads coverage and a
great deal of confidence as you can see
we stand out very clearly in the pile up
tonight GP we've also done this on the
RNA sides the translocations are a
critical part of being able to correctly
call these particular specimens and
index women of clinical Sims and one of
the more important translocations will
associate with Trump with Tyreke answer
is X 8 PP our gamma so since we have a
transportation fool we have an MRA pool
we can use both arose cool designs to
our advantage we can first detect the
translocation for example as a practice
AP PR gamma fusion but then we can see
confirmation by virtue of its three
prime partner of that fusion of the PPR
gamma mrna in the mRNA enrichment pool
we can see that it's specifically
elevated in cases and only in cases
where the translocation is present so
the plot here shows in red those that
have the translocation and those in
black that do not and the points that
really stand out in RAM are those that
have very high expression of the fusion
partner as expected so now in the post
analytical part with the bioinformatics
that can interpret across many of these
different types of markers and put this
into a broader perspective I think I'd
like to just wrap up with a clinical
study that we did that highlighted the
value of these many different types of
markers so in this particular clinical
research study
looked at 50 in determinants of fine
needle aspiration samples by psychology
so these are samples that have not given
any type of clear indication of cancer
and many of these patients in fact end
up going on to surgery we tested them
with a 17 marker probation say that
represents very well established markers
by the American thyroid association
conventional markers in DNA and RNA what
we observed from this cohort of 50
different is permanent is that we can
call about 75% of the malignant samples
and these were split out by b-raf status
Raffe status or with translocations of
red PT c of x appr gamma however there's
a black hole here of about twenty six
percent that is unexplained in malignant
so all of these samples are in fact
malignant and yet the conventional
markers only cover about three-quarters
of them how does that compare with our
114 comprehensive panel it spans many
more DNA and importantly RNA markers and
most importantly spans many different
categories of markers and indicates you
can see we can seal the gap and we can
explain the dark matter of this whole
with unexplained with conventional
marker set so we're still calling me to
of course a beer after the rasim the
conventional translocations but now we
can close this gap with malignancy with
novel translocations novel mutations and
importantly novel expression markers so
we can explain almost the totality of
this pie in addition to having a very
high sensitivity the assay does have a
high specificity as well and where we
did see lapses in specificity about half
of those that were called were
associated with grass or impacts attr
gamma translocations which had been
observed by many others in other
examples that maybe I'm pre malignant so
this technology for thyroid cancers been
license to interface diagnostics and it
represents the real power of integrating
across many different marker types for a
specific cancer and if applicable I
think too many other cancers in the
college
so I'll wrap up on this segment by
commenting on the value of this
particular approach to maximize workflow
efficiencies this isn't a bolt-on of an
RNA panel with a DNA panel this is a
truly integrated system that was built
from the ground up to accommodate
multiple types of markers across and
both of those nucleic acid types that it
considers as interpretations and provide
intra-assay confirmation which is a
powerful feature for having confidence
in clinical output that you can get
diagnostic value by looking at pathways
at a much broader level than just
individual mutations and that ultimately
this approach can advance drug
development in clinical trials by taking
the most informative content from DNA
from RNA etc and putting it into a
validated assay configuration that can
be amenable in a workflow for routine
testing so at this point we'll conclude
and we'll wrap our flips from QA on the
webinar
so moving into the Q&A session looks
like the first question relates to RNA
seek and it is how does your ffpe RNA
seek workflow compared to the alumina
access at a PR NHC you can say so to
answer this first of all I should say
that we have not done head-to-head
comparison but between our our workflow
and the alumina access kit as I
understand element access kit works by
selective enrichment of exome sequences
for a capture based approach however I
do know that the the metric they used
for pre sequencing QC is the based on
the bioanalyzer % DV two hundred and
from our experiences with our workflow
what we find is that the % DV 200 is
actually not very predictive post
sequencing data quality at least in the
context of our assay and this may be
related in some way to the capture of
used but what we find is that many
samples to fall below the cutoff that's
recommended for access which is the
thirty percent DV 200 where it because
many libraries that come in it at
reasonable and high quality in spite of
their low DB 200 score so I can speak to
that aspect of eclectic a head-to-head
comparison between several different
approaches for FF p RNA seek would be
warranted the future to understand which
is most appropriate approach for
different clinical applications
okay one questions come in is that other
than thyroid cancer what do these areas
do you think that a combination traded
DNA and RNA sequencing with provide
value I think is a good question because
the type of perche we've described is
applicable to a number of different
types of cancers a good example would be
lung cancer in this case we know that
there are a number of mutations of the
world defined for each if our k rafts
and other targets are highly actionable
for targeted therapies but we also know
there's an emerging landscape for
translocations with EML for al as well
as Ross and red fusions and that these
are also highly actionable so looking
more comprehensively and how these can
be put together not just disconnected
workflows and approaches the an approach
that looks at lung cancer specifically
and build a clinically minded as saying
that can put together both types of
these markers in the way it's
representative of how a precise medicine
lung cancer is being addressed something
could do very powerful feature another
target that's irrelevant to several
dairy farmers is p53 so you think about
peace treaty three in terms of until
next time sequencing asset but in
reality if there's a lot of power and
pulling together both DNA and RNA in my
context as well because we're looking at
not only the potential for a mutation in
p53 that can can lead to an activation
of protein and a consequence for those
individuals and patients but also the
fact that you have opportunity little
number of different isoforms of
expression of p53 as well as other
markers and an expression markers in
particular that may be able pt3 pathway
and affected by differences in few 53
relative activity so this can also help
maybe unravel some of the complexities
of how p53 manifests and different
cancers and the good tissue selective
expression and things of that sort
we allocated an hour for this webinar
running up against time at this point or
thank everybody for their participation
we received a great many questions and
we'll certainly be following up with
each and every one of those on behalf of
a surgeon in lavaridge thank you again
and have a great day